yeah i was living in a foster home
dropped out of high school
and recogni all i knew is i needed a
kick in the ass and i figured well
the marines they'll definitely do that
and they did not disappoint
so you're in f you were in foster homes
from what age uh that was
maybe i joined when i was 17 i guess
15. my parents divorced when i was young
and i bounced around and then you know a
lot of this was my own doing you know to
be perfectly honest with you i was you
know sort of done with my
parents and wanted to you know they had
moved from lake stevens and i was like
hey i'm not i'm not doing that
with all the wisdom that a 15 year old
possesses you know
and so this is what 1975
yeah if you want to round up a couple
years that'd be fine too but uh
but i'm saying it's 1975. you're 15
years old you're living in foster homes
you're like to hell with the parents i'm
doing my own thing
what did you have any uh did you think
we just just short sighted not
well it was you know actually it was a
little later than that my mother was a
writer she passed away last year
uh december year ago last december and
she was in south africa
if you ever saw that movie cry freedom
with denzel washington
it was about this guy donald woods who
was the editor of a newspaper over there
which
was on the coast of south africa she
worked for him
so i lost that whole year over there
with her in early 76 i came back because
the school didn't count right
oh so you went there you went to school
yeah i lived in east london south africa
between durban and cape town
and that was a little slice of the
marine corps right there i mean uniforms
haircuts and school and the whole deal
which you know i did not adjust well to
that by the way and i received the
caning
numerous canings for that oh they got
their corporal punishment
oh yeah bamboo canes i mean and once in
a wet speedo for not counting
off properly and mandatory pt and uh
you know i got religion pretty quick
learned how to count for sure
uh but uh yeah that's like prime
apartheid time nice it wasn't yeah and
this was this newspaper was obviously
against apartheid
so you know we were right in the middle
of all that i mean it was really stark
seeing the way that the way life was
over there so anyway i came back from
that i'd lost a year in high school and
i'm like well you know look i wasn't
you know an academic champion anyway so
i was like i'm just going to join the
marines and i am i
that's when i got back from there didn't
want to move back where my dad was i was
living with a guy and then a foster home
took me and it was that it's a pretty
cool story he
this family the williams family i'm
still in very close touch with him
their son had died he was a motocross
racing is big up there for
teenagers and he had died he was my
classmate jeff williams and he had died
in a motorcycle crash
and so i knew the family from afar not
not close i wasn't close friends with
jeff but but we knew each other
and so then it was sort of fortuitous
you know that i
providence that i came in his same age
and ended up with his family
and her the father charlie williams
was a former marine from korea uh and so
he was tell me about the marine corps
and i said that's what i need
so signed up and shipped out to the warm
embrace of the marine corps
so that did did what did he do in korea
did you
capture some of those stories that he
was in korea no
yeah he you know he was i think he was a
combat engineer
and uh you know so he was you know i
mean i don't remember a lot of them but
you know he talked a lot about combat
and how you know bad it's like but
really the best stories for him were
boot camp
you know they pulled all of it i never
forget one he said they pulled all of
his teeth out and we're giving him
dentures
you know when he's in boot camp right so
obviously dental care was not high on
his priority list
and right after he had that he had
stitches in his mouth and the drill
instructor pulled his dog tags
pulled him towards him real fast and
then extended his fists and punched him
in the mouth and his whole
you know mouth exploded with blood and
everything else and i was
supposed to be laughing at this yeah i
was like that sounds like fun i think
i'll join you know so
i mean those are most of his stories
where the trauma you know when i look at
full metal jacket and those boot camp
scenes i mean my
d.i said a lot of those same
phrases that they were i mean i thought
that was authentic what was that guy who
ended up being an
actor yeah yeah yeah he was you know the
yeah i guess at first he was a technical
guy but then he ended up
playing a part and i was like that dude
could have been staff sergeant amerine
who was my senior di when i went through
so
so you showed up there in 1978 so these
guys are yeah you're still getting
you're still getting vietnam guys that
are your drill instructors
yeah my company you know in the marine
corps and a company you have a first
sergeant
you know in the nco ranks you can sort
of split at e8 you can either be a
master sergeant or a first sergeant
and in a company you traditionally have
a first sergeant who sort of runs all
the admin
and all that then you have a master
sergeant who does ops right he's like
the ops art
and i remember my first observant i mean
he had one eye from vietnam and he was
illiterate
i mean he would sign like a x on the
duty roster and stuff like that
you know i mean yeah there was some
it was definitely a lot of vietnam era
guys there and how do you adapt
um candidly poorly at first you know i
mean
when i got there you know i mean it was
shock and awe
and i you know i certainly didn't want
to be there and for probably the first
few weeks thought i had made
a monumental error in judgment but
there was just enough in me that i felt
like hey
i'm you know i'm not going to go back to
my family hat and hand with my tail
between my legs so i just you know
tried to do it day at a time but i do
remember you know
the first morning they wake you up it's
brutal right trash cans thrown over
pulling people out of bunks and
you know there was a lot of physical
abuse back then i mean it was you know
measured but seemed pretty violent to me
um but you know i remember laying in a
in my rack every morning before you know
because i could hear them moving around
like little mice positioning themselves
before they launched the all-out assault
and uh you know i'd be laying her and
i'd be like well what do i have to look
forward to today
well that would be nothing so
once i got out of the rack and i started
going you're like a muscle memory i was
fine but those were the worst parts was
that morning laner
knowing this onslaught that was gonna
you know start there in a couple minutes
but all that being said you know i mean
and i and i think i was sort of a jack
wagon for my first comments typical
you know i did well in boot camp i got
whatever meritorious pfc and all that
i think primarily because my drill
instructor was hot for my sister
um but you know i could take any leg up
i could get
uh but you know the first couple years i
did all the stu i went to lejeune
to second mar div out there and i did
all the stupid stuff that young troops
did you know blow all my money for the
first three days after payday you know
thank god i had a meal carter i would
have starved to death
um but then you know i went to okinawa
to third mar div
and that's when the sort of the light
came on and i started going to school i
got my
diploma and started going to college and
i mean you know and then once you get a
little success
you know you sort of build on that i
mean there are setbacks along the way
but then i was like okay i can do this
you know what was your mos
i was an 1833 am tracker get some
yeah when you when you say was there
anything that made you realize
hey i need to kind of step up my game
maybe i should start you know going to
college maybe i should start my
continuing education maybe i should
start trying to get advanced
was there anything that in particular do
you have a leader that mentored you did
you just look around and say
man why don't i do a little bit better
well do you remember what that was was
it think one thing
yeah it wasn't you know there wasn't a
specific leader there were later in my
life certainly those that
you know that really inspired me to go
above and beyond um
but at that stage i think it was more
seeing people crash and burn around me
you know i mean getting guys getting
kicked out for drugs was rampant
back then i mean it was really ram i
mean and
uh and guys were getting caught we
didn't do urinalysis or anything like
that i mean they were just physically
cut with
you know drugs in the barracks it was
open bays back then we were open bay
barracks
at courthouse bay which is where our our
battalion was
and i just saw these guys and i mean i i
just saw him failing
and i mean i knew they were on a
downward spiral and i think
over time i saw enough of that where i
was like okay i don't want that to be me
and i went to okinawa with sort of in
you know
my own personal mandate to to turn my
life around and you know make something
of myself
hey you know listen it was never part of
the training on the training calendar
for me to be a general officer i remain
amazed of the flaws and the promotion
system to this day
but you know i just i just my goal was
to be a sergeant frankly that was my
goal
and uh and you know but you know you get
a little victory and you sort of build
on that
and you know and then lo and behold here
i am
you know flag flying and everything so
you know
as you know as a former aide you know
yeah yeah so
when you